hey guys I'm back for another video and
unfortunately I'm I'm really sorry to
tell you this but low-carb diets that
are now linked to atrial fibrillation I
know this is this is really this is
really scary because we're gonna have to
all go back to our high carbohydrate
diets you know based on this study yeah
I don't even know why I need to do this
video because this is ridiculous they
did a study and they found a link
between low carb and atrial fibrillation
which is a problem of the heart couple
problems with the study okay first of
all is it'll questionnaire is an
observational study which is the least
credible of all studies why because
there's an unlimited number of variables
that could cause this they showed that
the low-carb group increased risk for
atrial fib by 16% if we compared to the
high carb group if we compared the
low-carb to the moderate carb group it
was an increase in risk from two atrial
fib by eighteen percent that's pretty
scary
Wow increased by 16% or 18% and the
researcher who led the study stated
while the research shows an association
okay it can't prove cause an effect
alright guys so what is the big problem
with this study right here how they
defined low carbohydrates their
definition is forty four point eight
percent of the total calories being
carbohydrates guys that is not low-carb
when you do keto you're only doing five
percent of the total calories being
carbohydrates they're doing it you know
mere forty five percent that is a high
carbohydrate diet so really the so
called low carbohydrate study didn't
even evaluate low carbohydrates so
basically what they do is they take a
group of people who are consuming a high
amount of carbohydrates and they split
up into three groups and then they're
evaluating the relationship between high
carb to high carb high carb behind car
that's what they're doing okay and it's
very interesting because every week you
see this new study that comes out that's
scaring people okay well this is
completely false study because they're
putting doubt in people's mind when
they're not even evaluating low carbs
it's actually kind of ridiculous I mean
the next thing you know they'll probably
come out with something like I don't
know
cheeto crotch where your private parts
now have bad odor when you do keto or
something like that that would be
hilarious
so you know my viewpoint on this topic I
want to know your viewpoint what do you
think about this video go ahead and
comment down below